americans say they are afraid to speak
their minds a new poll finds 62 percent
of people have political views they now
say they're afraid
to share and these concerns do
cross-party lines the majority of
democrats independents and republicans
all agree
they don't feel safe to speak their
minds on politics all right
katie i want to start with you i thought
it was interesting digging into these
numbers there was
one group that self-identified that said
they feel that they have complete
freedom to speak out these are people
who describe themselves as quote strong
liberals 58 percent of them said they
have no worries at all
well i'm not shocked at all that they
have no worries at all considering they
are usually the ones
engaging in this so-called cancel
culture that we see but shannon i think
the implications for this are bigger
than just people feeling like they can't
speak politically whether it's with
their friends their family
we talk a whole lot about the 2016
election polling whether it was accurate
or not
there's a lot of questions this year
about whether pollsters will get it
right
between the race between joe biden and
president trump
and if you're afraid to speak your mind
politically do you really believe that
people on the phone
who are answering questions about their
political affiliation how
they feel about very sensitive topics
like race and the president
are telling the truth about the way that
they actually feel
i think that that puts a whole other
wrench into the situation with the
polling and whether you can actually
believe
that people think the way that they do
about the current state of the race
yeah and one that leads me to another
one of these numbers tucked in here 77
percent of conservatives said
they do not feel safe sharing anything
that was the biggest
group now does that give credence then
to what katie's saying to what the
president has said is there is a silent
majority out there
not feeling safe to talk about it or
talk to pollsters or post on facebook
but they're going to show up at the
ballot box
well you'd have to say that it's across
a lot of polls
uh it's not just one poll taken uh you
know by people on the left
i mean this it's it's fox polls it's i
mean it's
it's every poll so i don't know i mean
that's that would be pretty extreme
and also the numbers in many of these
polls shannon are double digits so again
that margin of error is pretty strong i
don't know but i mean it's always
possible
i i can tell you i i've been the victim
of
left wing type of canceled culture i was
fired from a job at npr
but i do think that most americans agree
that when it comes to slander lies
racist epithets and the like there
should be consequences
for that kind of talk the problem is
that we live in a very
politically polarized era the trump era
and i think lots of people use it as a
political weapon
uh to go after people they don't like or
people they disagree with and i also
think you have a lot of new voices in
newsrooms and on
social media platforms and they are
challenging a lot of the
existing powers that be in media and
sometimes the people in power don't like
being challenged in terms of what they
have to say so
to me it ruins opportunities for real
honest debate which is so necessary in a
good democracy we need to really be able
to speak to each other and i think
that's why people are upset
juan we're glad you came over to the fox
family uh greg i want to go to you
because he says
as juan points out there are younger
people different upstart kind of people
you know there's this whole conversation
about people um you know feeling like
twitter is controlling the new york
times the younger folks controlling it
the polls also show that gen z and
millennials are more comfortable with
cancel culture and think it serves a
real purpose
uh than any other age group not so
surprising
well and and i would dispute juan
calling this the trump era
this started well before trump it was
the personalization of politics
which was begun in the 60s by the left
that if you were for
say the vietnam war you wanted to kill
babies so this whole personal
personalization that the political is
personal began with the left
it's not the trumpers who are doxing
people it's not the trumpers that are
setting fire to buildings
it's not trumpers that are dumping trash
on people's porches
or vandalizing it is the left it is the
regressive left and the first amendment
it doesn't protect you with this stuff
because it doesn't protect you from
getting your career ruined
or your family threatened or your
reputation
an amazing contrast to see how
the loudest voices on the left claim
that their voices are being silenced
no one silenced them as they go out and
they try to silence people
through physical intimidation through
doxxing if i dare anybody to say blue
lives matter and see what happens to
them right
right what'll happen to them you can't
wear a red hat in a public place
even if it's even if it looks like a
trump hat and
corporations and businesses are so
scared
of social media that they just quiver
whenever there's a mob
they have to stop they have to grow a
pair and realize
that boycotters don't matter if they
didn't like
your stuff to begin with people who
claim they're boycotting your
tv show weren't watching it so your
advertisers
and your companies you got to stand up
all right you got to protect your
employees
yeah and jesse i mean people are worried
about their livelihoods
and employees are worried because a
third of the people in the survey also
said they actually think it could cost
them their job or promotion
and we hear stories about people saying
listen they found out i was a trump
supporter and either i got demoted or i
didn't get the gig
they're not going to say that but people
worry that that's what's behind these
employment decisions
and i worry more than anybody shannon
especially much more than you man they
might find out i'm a trump supporter
here and kick me out no i'm kidding um
juan you know you got fired from npr
for something really ridiculous but
that's how we all
feel we're all juan williams is in
america
we're basically all wands walking around
at npr
afraid to say how we really feel and
i mean and what you said wasn't even
that bad so
that's how we feel the only place i say
how i really feel
is on this show and i'm still holding
about 10 to 15 percent back
um you i don't say how i really feel
around my parents
i mean i don't say how i really feel at
a restaurant
you say how you really feel among your
friends and i agree with juan your last
point it's destroying honesty in america
and it's really holding this country
back because i bet if you ask people how
they
really felt about trade
illegal immigration jobs black lives
matter
i'd bet you get a very different opinion
if that wasn't in a poll if that was
something they just told their friends
well jesse you're going to get a money
the mom text is coming i mean jesse says
he's holding about 10 to 15 percent
i mean we're having that's coming
worried about my life jesse day 100